disney employees begin relocating from
california to florida business friendly
climate this is a fox business story
some of the 2000 walt disney company
employees who are being moved from
california to florida are already eyeing
up the housing market near orlando
disney announced in july that it would
move two thousand employees from
california to florida and part of the
florida business friendly climate it's
not just two thousand employees it's two
thousand employ uh it's not just two
thousand employees it's two thousand
employees their families and extended
families one realtor said i also kind of
panicked and was like gosh we don't have
enough inventory as it is
more buyers coming in is going to make
it very difficult to win bids for these
buyers and we're trying to help the
median price of a home is far below
california sitting at 318 for florida
versus
951 in california
did you hear that it's unbelievable 318
times 9.51 exactly three times higher
and that's wow and that's the state of
california that's not los angeles no
that's not the last thing that's stable
you know i'll jump on this really
quickly because i'm the only one that
doesn't live in florida um you know it's
amazing we go from a story where people
don't want to work
sorry tom it's the same thing right
go from a story where people don't want
to list the palm trees and beach
to where people will
leave everything and cross the entire
country with their family for that job i
think this is going to be fun to do a
follow-up in about a year because these
are great headlines this is very
interesting and you leave california i
totally get it on the business side but
it'll be interesting to see how some of
these families adjust because there will
be culture shock involved in some of
these moves for people if you lived in
california your whole life and you moved
to florida it's going to take an
adjustment it's different right the
weather's different the ocean is on the
opposite side of what you're used to i
find that just weird right you go to the
ocean you always assume you're going
west i bet that took you a little while
too in california now here it's the
exact opposite interesting you know i
find that you know that's how i figure
out my directions if i'm going towards
the ocean i know north is that way i
gotta admit i haven't thought of that
once yeah that was pretty cool though
but the other thing too i mean there's
just so many aspects of your life if
you're a sports fan how do you get used
to the game starting that much later
you're used to watching a nfl game
starting at six o'clock in prime time or
5 30 and now you're not going to bed
till 1 a.m if you want to stay to the
end of it so it's interesting totally
makes sense these companies are doing it
it'll be interesting to see what type of
toll or what kind of effects this has on
people that have made this move uh it
might be all worth it because of the
cost you can get such a bigger house
your life can change instantly and and
you know what we know it shonda and i
had to go to arizona on friday you just
feel different when you go into a state
like arizona or you go to texas or you
go to florida like i do every week or
you go to california for a day there's
differences when you can walk into a
place of business and not think did i
bring my mask
it's a totally different world i mean
seriously you panic in california i
don't have my mask what do i do oh my
god i don't have it can i pull my
my shirt up over my face will that work
you know they're getting a little bit
lacked because i think store owners and
business owners are sick of it as well
but it's just different when you come
out here it's freedom it feels wonderful
look i love this story because i
remember when bob iger talked about the
fact that they had to let go of 78 000
employees in california and he was a guy
that was sitting on newsome's board
helping him out right yeah and then he
resigned he says look i'm not playing
this game with you because you're
hurting all these families here while
the businesses around disney world were
doing okay because it was still open
people could still go there and then
fast forward 12 months later 16 months
later florida desantis was seen as an
irresponsible governor now their covet
the uh
cases are lower than the state of
california who's like the responsible
state so this is not a good look for
california this is a great look for
florida but i will tell you behind
closed doors a lot of floridians don't
want people from california to come here
and that's straight
from up to come to florida there's a
bigger story underneath this right now
the the headline is 2 000 people are
going to drive up the price of housing
because they're selling an expensive
house coming to florida they're going to
be able to bid higher and you know our
and the realtor is saying am i even
going to be able to help you the bigger
story here is that disney is very
quietly
moved 2 000 people from the walt disney
company and these weren't theme park
workers
and they have moved in operation it's
not about the 2000 that are there now
it's about the next thousand that
they're going to be hiring in the next
five years and disney is saying that
florida is a better business climate and
i'm moving a massive division to florida
and they're probably going to get a
little bit of wage moderation and
regulation moderation definitely versus
california the bigger story is the mouse
doesn't want to say out loud that
they're leaving california and they're
very happy to have the narrative be
about this migration of people and stuff
but the mouse is moving a division to
florida because they think it's a better
place to do business and just like texas
when toyota move all those people from
hawthorne california to dallas you know
texas a lot of texas citizens were like
okay so we got a lot of blue people
coming here slowly tinting us on the
vote toward lavender and they're not
looking for that but toyota did it for
economic reasons too nobody wants to go
out and criticize the state of
california in public but there are
businesses that continue to move out big
businesses who try to show this nice
rainbow flag
we're okay with everybody everything's
cool it's all here yay and and donate
politically and stuff while very quietly
and economically moving yeah think of
the decision making involved in moving 2
000 people that's a lot of logistics and
i will say this about disney when that
initial release came out where they said
they're moving these 2 000 workers they
did say that the california business
climate is way less attractive than
florida they did call them out a little
bit so i think that to a certain extent
they're not afraid of saying it now if
you're going to make that big of a
decision to move i mean i think you you
know everybody knows why and it's okay
to say it all right let's talk about
just waiting for in and out to move to
cal to florida i've already i've already
made my commitment
if they come here i will buy one
franchise from them even though they
don't do it anymore i will gladly buy
one from hey you know what i think pat i
think this office will keep you in
business pat that was that was a novelty
story initially but that thing's got
like some real legs i mean if the actual
ceo is talking to the governor of the
state of california state of florida the
state of florida it's more than just
it's not just like a publicity stunt
david got a shout out yeah
governor mayor david is his
emperor now that's a perfect question
right there so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you